pourquoi l'amour
l'absence d'amour la fin de l'amour le
besoin d'amour
engendre tellement de violence
[Musique]
c'était une question de temps avant que
ça n'arrive
on pouvait refaire le chemin en arrière
en suivant les miettes jusqu'aux
origines de la violence avec le recul on
pouvait voir qu'elle était partout
ça fait partie de notre foi de pardonner
nous serons contraintes de quitter la
colonie si nous ne pardonnons pas à ces
hommes
vous refusez toutes d'entendre raison on
sait qu'on a pas imaginé ces agressions
on sait qu'on est meurtri et
[Musique]
c'est mieux que la haine de ce qui est
familier
on ne peut pas supporter d'autres
violences
[Musique]
nous avons été traités comme des animaux
peut-être que nous devrions réagir comme
des animaux
comment tu te sentirais si durant toute
ta vie
tu avais eu le sentiment que ton opinion
ne comptait pas
quand on sera parvenu à se libérer
il faudra qu'on se demande qui on est
[Musique]